hello everyone and welcome to today's
presentation
rapid hyperplex staining and
simultaneous imaging for
immunophenotyping of tissue sections
i'm identi head of marketing and
communications at lunaform
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event today's webinar
is brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by lunafore
so if you would like to have any more
information about us luna 4
please visit our site at lunafore.com
before we begin i'd like to remind
everyone that this is an interactive
event so we encourage you to participate
by submitting
as many questions as you want at any
time you want
during this presentation and to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click
on the send button if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located at the far left of your screen
so now i'd like to welcome today's
speaker
dr diego gabriel dupuis chief technology
officer at luna for technologies
today dr dupree will introduce you to
our microfluidic technology and and our
product comet currently in development
that features integrated imaging and
staining of tissue samples
he will then show you how the staining
and imaging integration is achieved
and also how we optimize assays to
obtain hyperplex results
in short-term times thanks to our novel
microfluidic technology
and finally he will focus on protocol
transfer to different tissue types
and after which we will have a live q a
where we as mentioned before
we will answer the questions received
during the presentation
if you would like to know more about our
presenter please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen
so with this said i think dr duffy you
may now begin your presentation
thanks urania for the nice introduction
good morning
good afternoon good evening everyone
it's a great pleasure for me to present
at this lab webinar
our product under development comet is
an all-in-one staining and imaging
platform
that integrates our microfluidic-based
staining with a fluorescence microscopy
it can run extremely rapid hyperplex
assays
in an automated fashion since it's an
open system
it allows the use of label-free
off-the-shelf or custom primary
antibodies
for more information about our product
and the development do not hesitate to
reach us
to communications at lunafore.com
the core of our technology is based on a
microfluidic chip called
mtp for microfluidic tissue processor
it is used to reach high performance
automation of in-situ staining
techniques
on tissue samples such as hyplex
immunofluorescence
the chip is a set of microfluidic
channels designed to deliver and wash
reagents on the vicinity of the sample
it is clamped over standard histological
glass lights
forming a close chamber of reaction over
the tissue
we call this technology ffx for fast
fluidic exchange
this name is due to the fact that
pressure-driven reagents
flow into the chamber and the liquid
exchange is very rapid
the perfect ceiling offers a controlled
environment with multiple benefits
staining times are reduced due to the
active transport of reagents
a more uniform staining over the tissue
surface is achieved and evaporation is
avoided
a heating element placed below the slide
allows for precise temperature control
and at any time as well as rapid
temperature changes
thanks to the limited heat capacity of
the assembly
finally our microfluidic chips have an
integrated glass imaging window
that allows for integrated staining and
imaging
this way the user does not need to move
samples from staining stations to
imaging stations
neither perform multiple cover sleeping
steps
our technology has been widely validated
across a number of
studies and publication we've
demonstrated
that running microfluidic-based
immunofluorescence assays
with short incubation times we can
better quantify the fluorescent signal
from the tissue
thanks to the avoidance of saturation
we could even classify ambiguous her2
status of breast carcinomas into fish
positive
and negative basing ourselves on the
quantification of the fluorescence her2
staining
we have also shown that we can obtain
extremely rapid chromogenic and
fluorescence
stainings on different markers of both
formally fixed paraffin-embedding and
frozen samples
additionally we've shown that dna and
rna
can be preserved during the staining
performed with our instrument
and the samples can be further utilized
after staining for next generation
sequencing
with our technology we can also run fish
assays and target rna expression
you might have watched our seminar
showing the capability of our product
lapsa
to run tyramid signal amplification
based multiplexing assays in combination
with the oppal
kits from akoya if you missed it
you can find it in our website or just
get in touch by email
finally in this presentation i'd like to
introduce you to the use of our
technology to perform multiplexing
assays in a sequential fashion
our sequential immunofluorescence assay
consists of the following steps
we incubate a cocktail of two primary
antibodies of different species
subsequently we incubate a cocktail of
two fluorescently labeled secondary
antibodies
and we acquire the image we then remove
all the antibodies using an illusion
buffer
and heat we repeat this process
over and over again
the instrument will automatically
register stack and stitch
all the images
every sequential monofluorescent cycle
consists of the incubation
of two primary antibodies from different
species
in our case mouse on rabbit for two
to four minutes followed by a two-minute
incubation of a cocktail of two
fluorescently labeled goat antibodies
and finally a one-minute incubation with
dappy
the overall staining cycle lasts 10 to
12 minutes
after the staining is finalized the
tissue scans through the imaging window
of a microfluidic chip
know the coupling between the staining
chip and the sample is required and the
process is performed
in an automated fashion in the data that
i am showing today we scan areas of 4
by 4 square millimeters
the total cycle of staining scanning and
illusion
takes around 25 minutes generating three
stitched
images dappy and two markers of interest
we can repeat this cycle for as long as
we'd like to
we have shown results for up to 15
cycles giving 30 plex
staining as of today but we expect this
count to keep growing
once all the images have been acquired
the registration and stacking process
takes place
before a multiplexing assay can be
performed we need to go through a series
of
steps of optimization
our technology allows for playing with
multiple parameters at temperature
incubation time the use of dynamic
incubations to achieve more homogeneous
sustaining
perform multiple flashes etc
to achieve a good multiplexing
experiment
we make sure that we can remove the
signal of every staining
in order to avoid non-specific signal
appearing downstream in the protocol
for this reason every marker goes
through an illusion characterization
step
where we make sure that at least 99
of the signal is removed we compare the
remaining fluorescence after allusion to
the autofluorescence of the tissue
obtained prior to starting the
optimization procedure
a similar background level indicates an
efficient
illusion of secondary antibodies from
the tissue
subsequently we perform a control
staining using only the secondary
antibodies
and compare the fluorescence signal with
a reference negative control
the scope of this step is to highlight
any remaining primary antibody after the
illusion
once marker optimization is achieved and
the elusion efficiency is proven to be
above the acceptance criteria
every marker goes through an epitope
stability characterization step
where multiple cycles of evolution are
performed intercalating
staining controls in the
in process example of this study we show
an initial staining of cd20
followed by 10 cycles of evolution and
the second staining
after 15 dilution cycles a third cd20
staining
was performed we compare the signal
intensities
and background levels for each step
the information gathered during elusion
efficiency and epitope stability
characterization is fundamental when
creating a multiplexing panels
as it will determine how difficult it
will be to remove the signal from a
particular marker
and how stable the epitope is to
multiple cycles of evolution
this ultimately guides us on what
position to assign each marker to
in our multiplexing panel
once every marker in our panel has been
characterized we are ready to create the
multiplexing protocol
in the example you see in this slide 24
immune markers were stained on formally
fixed paraffin-embedded human tonsils
the scanning area was set to 4x4 square
millimeters
and the total time of the experiment was
5 hours
we also used chromogenic references for
every marker as the benchmark
for the areas we were expecting to see
signal
subsequently we transferred our
protocols to samples of non-small cell
lung carcinomas
and compared again with the chromogenic
gold standard
we know that performing quantitative
comparisons
between chromogenic and fluorescence
images is not straightforward
so we came up with two simple image
processing
algorithms that would allow us to
determine the area of the tissue that
was stained
both in chromogenic and fluorescence and
plotted those values
in a scatterplot both for tonsil
and lung carcinomas we could appreciate
a very good correlation
between both stainings in both tissue
types
it is widely accepted to employ tonsil
samples during the early optimization of
immune markers
due to the easy access to tissue and the
abundance of the expression of such
markers
however this comes with additional
difficulties
very often we need to perform some
re-optimization steps once we transfer
to specific tissue types
in some cases only one or a few tissue
types require adaptation
well in other cases a more general
re-optimization is required
for example this was our approach to
transfer this 7 marker panel from tonsil
tissue
to colorectal cancer lung carcinoma and
melanoma
when we attempted to transfer cd3 and
cd4
screening confirmed no need to further
optimize
online and melanoma we increase antibody
primary antibody and secondary antibody
concentration in colorectal
tissue for optimal results
we will typically look at readjusting
the concentration of primary antibodies
first
and or the incubation time
as a second step we could also play with
the concentration of the secondary
antibody and decide or not
to include an additional blocking step
for fox p3
pd1 and pdl1 we required
increasing only the secondary antibody
concentration on colorectal
and lung tissue
for cd68 we increased primary antibody
concentration on all three tissue types
and finally in more difficult cases even
if a starting tonsil protocol seems to
work
the transfer to tissue would require the
choice of an alternative clone
this was our case for cd8
to conclude tonsils helped set the
starting point for many markers during
the optimization of our multiplexing
protocol
however when transferring to specific
tissue types
a subgroup of the markers require
further adjustment our technology allows
for testing of multiple conditions in
series
with limited need of transferring the
samples from a stainer to a scanner
avoiding many manual steps of cover
sleeping and decover sleeping
i'd like to show you a sample image of a
transfer from tonsil to colorectal
cancer
that we obtained in collaboration with
professor intislovech
from the university of bern in
switzerland
we have optimized a six plex panel on
colorectal cancer
as the preliminary steps towards a
larger panel
in this case we apply the background
removal algorithm
that was developed in-house and that
takes into account the autofluorescence
of the tissue
acquired automatically at the beginning
of the essay
the last step of this presentation is
simply to highlight that the images
generated with the comet instrument are
exported in ome tiff
format making it possible to import from
most tissue analysis tools
on the left hand side we perform cell
segmentation using the startest
algorithm on qpas then we trained
a classifier to recognize fox p3
positive cells
on the right hand side we used an
ai-based algorithm from halo
for cell segmentation on one of our
comet images
i hope i have been able to show how the
use of microfluidics
allows for rapid and efficient staining
and elusion cycles of tissue samples
we've discussed how our technology can
be used in combination with an
integrated fluorescence
scanner and how this enables full
automation
and finally it is important to mention
that the product we are developing
combines an integrated staining and
imaging workflow
with forced light capacity comet will
allow
researchers to run their project without
compromising in terms of plex level
or number of samples my team and i are
now happy to answer your questions
thank you very much for your question
presentation diego
um before we start the q a i want to
mention that we will be sharing this
recording
on our company website so
www.lunafor.com
so let's start with the q a we will go
through as many questions as we have
time for
but we are if we're not able to answer
all of them we will surely get in touch
with you
um to reply any pending questions uh or
if you would like to submit any more
questions after the q a is over
you can also do so via email by sending
an email to
communications at lunafore.com
all right so let's go ahead and get
started we have already some questions
coming in
the first question that we have is
can we use any desirable marker is a
platform
open any requisites for antibodies
that's a very interesting question so
yes the
platform is open so we can use any
marker of interest
there is no particular requirement
neither uh
from the point of view of barcoding or
whatsoever the only specification that
we need
is that the fluorophores that we use in
conjugation with the secondary
antibodies
have the right match in terms of
emission and excitation
spectrum
great um we have another question here
regarding
the type of sample so this question is
asking what is the thickness of the
sections that we can use
so we typically use samples of
ffp samples mounted on standard
histological glass slides
of about two to five microns thick
excellent um another uh attendee was
asking about
how if you could clarify how you raised
the signal
in in this application
yeah this is a very important uh point
we we've been optimizing on this uh
since uh the very beginning of the
development so it's a combination
of low ph and detergent
and heat and what we do is we elude so
we really remove
the complex of primary and secondary
antibodies from the tissue
excellent i see more questions coming in
this is great so
please go ahead we have another question
asking can we identify intracellular
markers
yes we can we can we have experience i
mean we have
data showing that we can detect all
types of markers
memorize markers like the plasmatic
markers and nuclear markers
we have for example optimize fox p3 k67
and et cetera
um someone else is asking is it possible
to use uh cocktails of antibodies in a
single staining
uh staining an imaging cycle
yeah this is very important question as
i
i
showed in the presentation so basically
we
designed um the experiment so that we
can target two markers per cycle
of off-the-shelf uh antibodies normally
of two species
typically one mouse one rabbit
so yes we can cocktail but they don't
necessarily need to be mouse and rabbit
great another question on sample type so
this question is asking is this method
restricted for use on specific tissue
types or it can't be used on any tissue
type
so we have experience with different
tissue types
both normal tissue and cancerous tissues
so there is no no restriction from that
and on top of this this we are
very interested in frozen sections as
well we have plans of developing um
the stainless and frozen sections and we
already have
experience on the staining itself i'm
sorry we are developing now the
multiplexing protocol for them as well
excellent um another question here is
asking whether
antigen retrieval is performed prior
to this application or automated on the
device
yeah this is very important so we
the antigen retrieval needs to be done
offline
so on an another instrument prior to
being mounted into
uh loaded into our system uh but we are
optimizing it with a module that is
uh automated uh however the user can
choose whether
what method to use for the waxing and
antigen retrieval
the way we're suggesting is using an
instrument in order to get it automated
what about the maximum sample type size
that you can evaluate
so the evaluation area is a maximum of
nine by nine
square millimeters and we are interested
in going further in the future but this
is uh
our our current uh area that we can
evaluate
excellent we have another question
coming in
um someone is asking what resolution or
zoom can you use or can you achieve with
this device are details visible at the
cellular level
all right so we are going to reach
under the 0.5 micrometers in resolution
uh we are going to do so by having a
rather high numerical aperture objective
and a combination with a very high
quality cmos camera
and as i mentioned before we can target
markers that are either nuclear
cytoplasmatic
or membrane i don't i don't see we i
don't think that with epifluorescence uh
we could go any further than that in
general let's say an optics limitation
another question coming in this one is
saying
could you please give a rough estimation
of the staining time per sample for a 20
flex panel
yeah so um we do have an average but
it's a little bit big so i would rather
give some examples of it so for
um like i think one of them i showed in
the presentation a 24
uh marker panel scanning
four by four square millimeters takes
five hours
and another example of 30 plex
took us eight hours for a nine by nine
square millimeter area
excellent um someone else is asking here
what's the maximum number of markers i
think it says
tried with this technology i'm guessing
that's the type of
trite with this technology
yes we have data so far showing 30 plex
with our technology
well we are the the count keeps
increasing as we speak
uh what is the actual uh estimate of a
number of plagues that we will deliver
uh with with comet maybe that is also an
interesting question for our attendants
so we designed the instrument to reach
40 plex
but we are not setting ourselves an
upper limit for it
um some attendees are asking about some
more details for
about the microscope so what what what
can you
tell us about the microscope coupled
with comets so for instance
magnifications
uh can we choose one area or more etc
all right so the comment has one
objective so in terms of
um objective magnification is a 20x
however because we use a rather high
numerical aperture objective we can
we can zoom in and look at the tissue as
if it was
as if it was i'm sorry a 40x
magnification in classical
pathology images let's say um
and then we can take the regions of
interest as we
as we like i hope i answer the question
yes we can we can choose several regions
of interest this is very interesting
exactly um so uh some more questions
coming in
what floor force can be used in the
secondary antibodies
uh this is important so it has to match
the
emission and excitation uh spectrum of
the filters that we have
integrated in our instrument so we
optimized
for the p of course alexa floor 555
and alexa floor 647
so as long as the fluorophore that is
conjugated to the secondary antibodies
covers that then there is no real other
specification
for what kind of secondary antibody we
need
creates another question coming in so
how can one make use of this technology
for cell line samples or cell suspension
as well as
culturistic cells unfortunately we don't
have data on that
but we'd be happy to take this offline
and and come up with a project for
example together to regenerate the data
does the repeating the illusion process
hamper the markers to be stained at the
end
yeah this is a very important point so
this is the reason why when we do
uh the optimization for every single
uh marker we do it in a monoplex basis
but we do what we call
elusion efficiency and epitope stability
studies
it will give us an idea of how far we
can go in the illusion for each epitope
and allow us to decide whether we have
to
localize localize at the beginning in
the middle of the end or in the end of
our
eventual multiplexing experiment each
marker
so yes to some epitopes that can
the illusion can harm um can
yeah this the binding however
we can manage it by characterizing the
marker
during optimization excellent
we are almost reaching the end we have a
couple more questions
so if you have any more please send them
now
the next question says regarding the
analysis of
images how many colloquialized markers
can be detected with your system
uh for most softwares we are used to a
maximum of three localized markers
that can be detected
yeah i'm uh this is very interesting i'm
not sure i completely understand the
question
so what we are doing is in every cycle
we get three images we get one dappy
image
marker a and marker b we take the image
then we elude and we stain again
so we are colloquializing at the same
time let's say
three mark two markers plus dappy but we
do it over and over again and we have
our own proprietary
um stitching and alignment alignment
algorithm that will allow us to
collocalize
really all the cycles therefore reaching
the 40 plex
and actually connected to to this
process
the last question asks is the
registration software included when
multiplexing
yes absolutely so the software that we
provide with the instrument
will give the images already stitched
uh registered in all together as one
mosaic let's say in ome tiff
format so that you can downstream open
it
on any image analysis or tissue analysis
tool that you'd like to use
great this is very clear so the q a is
coming to an end
we have no more questions so please
remember that we will be sharing
uh this recording on our company website
uh www.lunafor.com
and if you would like to submit any more
questions later on uh please do so
via email by sending a message to
communications
lunafore.com um again thank you to
everyone for attending this webinar
uh thank you dr dupree for this very
insightful presentation
and and q a and we're looking forward to
receiving any additional questions from
uh everyone else and uh anything you
might want to know about lunaforce
technology or if you're interested in a
possible collaborations we are very open
for a discussion
so with this i wish you all a great rest
of the day and thank you very much